Emmanuel Lambert c'est facile comme
transition vous êtes donc à l'origine de
ce spectacle mémoire du lieu où comment
noyer le poisson journée du patrimoine
donc à Saint-Quentin les horaires c'est
à retrouver hein bien sûr sur sur le
site internet de Saint-Quentin en
Yveline c'est un spectacle drôle que
vous avez développé vous inventez
l'histoire du lieu en fait c'est un
petit peu ça l'idée on réinvente
l'histoire du lieu voilà donc le musée
de daville nous a demandé de revisiter
le quartier euh à chaque fois on prend
quelqu'un du passé qui a vraiment existé
donc là il se trouve que c'est l'abé
picar qui a était à l'origine de du
creusement des canaux qu' jusqu'à
Versailles et euh on lui ainventé une
histoire surréaliste et on va montrer
que c'est lui qui a été non seulement
l'inventeur du premier sèche-elinge de
l'histoire au 15e siècle et qui a fait
que la ville de saint-quantin en Yveline
existe aujourd'hui donc une relecture
par l'absurde vous avez pas peur que les
enfants croi ce que vous racontez les
adultes aussi j'espère bien l'idée c'est
ça c'est de se servir du vrai euh et des
choses qui sont vrais qui paraissent euh
abérantes et aussi de rajouter du faux
dedans et après à chacun de démêler et
on espère que ça donne les gens en
général passent un bon moment fait ça
dans pas mal de villes en France et
après ça peut donner envie aussi
l'histoire
de au patrimoine d'amener à l'histoire
par par l'humour voilà c'est ça voilà ou
ouais en posant un problème de fond on a
tout le temps une partie oui
humoristique on va traiter de manière
décalée et absurde et on pose un
problème de fond sur qu'est-ce que c'est
que le patrimoine dans cette ville-ci
donc là dans à 5 an divine voilà qu vous
l'aviez fait dans quelle commune
auparavant ça fait 3 ans qu'on tourne le
spectacle on a on a fait àep à rouan on
l' fait pas mal aussi autour de Nant par
chez nous puisque ch
h justement ouis c'est pas difficile de
se réinventer de retrouver à chaque fois
on a une petite dizaine de jours pour de
jours de représentation après donc le
but c'est d'emmagaziner des informations
assez vite tout ce qui est vrai
justement parce que nous on débarque
dans une ville qu'on connaît pas après
de l'adapter au lieu au parcours qu'on
choisit on a SEP scène et puis bah
d'emmener les gens dans un univers
complètement décalé ou et votre adage
pour conclure c'est faire croire à
l'invraisemblable car c'est la seule
évidence voilà voilà c'est d'ordre de
cette compagnie et bien évidemment vous
envoyer quelques images de ces
répétitions de cet après-midi le
reportage complet aussi pour avoir un
aperçu de ce que vous allez proposer ce
sera dans l'édition de lactum et de
demain programme terich donc sur TVfil
toutes nos vidéos si vous êtes un peu
perdu sur retrouver sur notre site
internet bien évidemment merci à tous
les deux d'être passés sur ce plateau
merci Joanna également pour la
préparation de cette édition spéciale
journée du patrimoine puisqu'on parle
culture sachez aussi que sur notre site
Internet vous pouvez gagner des places
pour l'opération UGC Viva l'opéra
rubrique concours tout simplement des
places à gagner pour découvrir l'opéra
au cinéma réalisation ce soir romain
ruspini retour du 78 en direct à 18h
jeudi des athlètes ivelinois de retour
des Jeux Paralympiques de Londres seront
sur ce plateau excellente
soirée